women you can't live with them and you
can't live without him unless there are
seductive demoness who literally wants
to drain the life out of you because in
that case I think you can be excused for
wanting to stay away for those thinking
this sounds awfully familiar no we are
not talking about your ex-wife nor your
ex-girlfriend today's video is on the
succubus or the succubi if you want to
refer to them collectively when we think
of a succubus there are several things
that come to mind the more traditional
among you will think of a demon that
seduces men nowadays we just think of
them as attractive women and someone who
is merely search succubus into google
images we'll probably think it's some
kind of weird fetish and it probably is
some of you may even remember that train
wreck of a movie that was Jennifer's
body where Megan Fox and Amanda Seyfried
make out and then Megan Fox is like oh
I'm gonna eat that boy you like and the
Mantis I freed was like no screw you and
your weirdly shaped toe thumbs no
succubus gonna eat my man and that's
pretty much the whole story so I guess
we begin with the definition and the
origin a succubus is a demon that takes
the form of a woman which leads us to
the question of the day if the demon is
a man and then turns into a succubus is
that demonic catfishing who knows the
succubus can be traced back to medieval
folklore in these stories once a demon
has assumed its female form it then
comes to its victim in their dream and
the seduction process begins which is
then followed by some kind of sexual
activity which raises the question what
does the succubus gain from this I mean
sleeping with men in their dreams
doesn't seem to have much of an upside
but as you may expect there is an
ulterior motive behind this there are
more than a few theories as to why one
that you might be familiar with is the
idea of the succubus feeding off the man
either physically devouring his flesh or
taking parts of his soul numerous
encounters with a succubus are said to
leave the victim with a severe mental
deterioration causing hallucinations and
in the worst case death some even
believe the Sakya bus was used as a way
to explain sleep paralysis the world
succubus derives from several different
Latin terms one of these beings tsukuba
which roughly translates to mean lies
beneath or lies beneath the bed
this also relates to the succubus
position in relation to the victim
there are several accounts of the
succubus in Jewish folklore the most
famous example will be in Adam's first
wife and Lilith who refused to be
subservient and left the Garden of Eden
before becoming one of the four demon
Queens that slept of the ark angel
Samael the descriptions given are that
of a beautiful woman but up close you
can notice deformities such as
serpentine like tails and bird-like
Talon which sound quite similar to the
sirens of Greek myth and in the later
years these stories of the succubi were
replaced with stories of sirens they do
also bear a resemblance to another
creature from Greek mythology
Lamia and in turn the Lamia and impure
sir which were also rather repulsive
creatures that could alter their form in
order to seduce men but some choosing to
feed off the men they seduce and others
convincing young men to marry them only
to leave them the night before the
wedding
Lamia herself was one of Zeus's scorned
lovers that became a monster who
devoured men and children as revenge for
the very own children that she had lost
the word lilith was thought to derive
from a group of female demons in
Mesopotamian mythology named Lily - who
themselves are named after the demon
Lamas - who would kidnap children while
their mothers breastfed chewing on their
bones and drinking their blood
she was also described as having a
rather disturbing appearance so this
idea of succubi as grotesque demons who
steal children is one that spans across
more than just one culture throughout
religion the succubus is almost always
portrayed as a negative and evil figure
you would then expect most holy and
religious men to do whatever they could
to limit the power of the succubus but
there are a few holy men who claim not
every succubus is evil the best example
we have is probably pope sylvester ii
and yes i can appreciate the irony in a
pope defending a sex demon before pope
sylvester died he confessed everything
where he revealed that a succubus had
helped him climb to the ranks of the
catholic church he said that as a young
man he came across a woman named Mary
Deanna who promised him everything he
could ever dream of wealth good fortune
status and knowledge beyond anything any
mortal could teach him
there was only one condition that he
remained faithful to only her and so he
accepted he would eventually become Pope
and despite the vows that he took his
relationship with this woman continued
in secret there are some different
accounts to this story some believe he
was so hungry for power and money that
he summoned the demon that then took the
form of a succubus and that is why he
confessed on his deathbed whereas others
believed he simply fell in love and
refused to value his barrels over the
woman he loved which is why when he
eventually confessed he painted her in
such a positive light whether this is a
story about a horny Pope who found love
or a horny Pope we found a succubus I
guess we'll never know but it's safe to
say that he was probably a [ __ ] Pope
the Catholic Church all those associated
with it did have some quite interesting
ideas in regards to the succubi in 1487
a man by the name of Heinrich Kramer
published malleus Maleficarum better
known as the hammer of witches the work
itself detailed literature surrounding
demonology in the 15th century and
essentially it called for the
extermination of witches witchcraft was
of course forbidden by the church and
Kramer himself was once a clergyman
though he was later discredited as most
of what he wrote was inconsistent with
the already existing Catholic doctrines
surrounding demonology the book was then
condemned by the church for this exact
reason as well as by several German
universities because much of what he
described was either illegal or
unethical despite the efforts of the
religious and educational institutions
the book stirred up an immense amount of
interest only being outsold by the Bible
itself for the next 200 years or so now
as fascinating as this is I only mention
the book because Kramer does indeed
discuss the succubus
according to Kramer a succubus would
collect the semen of the men she slept
with and then give it to an incubus who
would use it to impregnate a human woman
this is how he explains demons could
sire children despite them being
incapable of traditional reproduction he
then goes on to say that children born
this way were far more susceptible to
demonic influence and possession whether
or not you believe any of this I guess
is down to you but the whole concept of
a demon woman stealing semen and then
given it to a demon man to impregnate a
human woman is pretty insane and even if
we ignore the scientific limitations of
Kramer's thinking what do the ink you
buy then do do they turn the semen into
demon semen on second thought I don't
really want to know
the work of Heinrich Kramer did create
some additional hysteria during the many
witch trials that took place as women
who attempted to seduce men were accused
of being a succubus in disguise and
women who fell pregnant outside of
wedlock was said to be harboring the
child of an incubus sounds like a
fantastically civilized time to exist
the way we look at the succubus now has
obviously changed to some the word may
still conjure up images of a demon but
even then I'd hazard a guess that the
demon isn't repulsive probably something
that looks like it belongs in some sort
of sex dungeon full of whips chains ball
gags and a host of items you wish you
could unsee anyway the moral of the
story is no matter how where do you
think people are there are always those
weirder March March weirder the image we
have today of a succubus is mostly that
of an extremely beautiful woman perfect
skin great hair and eyes you would
literally sell your soul for this is a
stark contrast from the scaly deform
succubi of old with their horns and
bat-like wings which are more akin to a
demon than a seductive enchantress
though if they can transform themselves
from a demon to a woman then it's not
too unreasonable to believe they can
change how human they look no I'm sure
it won't come as a surprise that we see
the succubus quite often in modern
fantasy Stephen King mentions them
several times in the Dark Tower series
where a succubus named Mia helps an
incubus impregnate a woman whose child
would then become a villain rather
similar to what Kramer said about how
demons reproduce as well as the idea
that the child of an incubus is more
likely to be swayed by evil Stephen King
also describes them as sexual vampires
and this connection between the succubi
and vampires does make sense and the
lines between them can be blurred
because of the predatory way they behave
when we think of vampires both male and
female much like the succubi they will
often seduce their victim before they
feed almost as if the chase or the
thrill of the hunt is what they really
take pleasure in now of course not all
vampires behave in this way the Strigoi
being a good example of vampires who
don't really care for the whole
seduction process this idea of female
vampires being succubi does also exist
in the Twilight series but for your sake
and as well as mine we're going to
pretend it doesn't exist and it never
has done ever we also have The Dresden
Files by Jim Butcher which does mention
succubi and incubi with the protagonists
half brother been an incubus described
as having vampire-like qualities most
people who played World of Warcraft
would have either had or seen a warlock
running around of a succubus as a pet
which is basically just a half-naked
demoness with hooves wings and a whip
which once again takes us back to the
age-old saying he who takes the succubus
as a pet is a weirdo it's interesting to
see the history behind the succubus and
how these ideas have changed over time
what started off as pretty much
disgusting demons that still children
became more and more visually appealing
and seductive but if we take the
religious influence into consideration
it's not really that much of a surprise
as corruption and temptation are
recurring themes throughout most of
religion what I find more surprising is
that plenty of authors and stories
actually do remain quite loyal to the
origin but of course there will also be
modern interpretations which are just
awful for anyone who wants a good laugh
I suggest watching the succubus
interaction in Devil May Cry it's
definitely the funniest I've seen if you
do have any thoughts and ideas or
perhaps you know of some interesting
stories that feature suck you by then
feel free to share those of me in the
comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained reminding you to
always say no to a succubus unless your
dream is to be Pope because in that case
knock yourself out